>> Greg: THE BEEFCAKE HACK IS
FINALLY BACK, AND FOR THIS, I
APPLAUD AND SHOUT THANK YOU GOD.
YES IT'S TRUE.
♪ ♪
>> IT'S BACK!
[LAUGHS]
ALL RIGHT!
YEAH!
>> Greg: CHRIS CUOMO ANNOUNCED
HE'S ACCEPTED AND ANCHOR JOB AT
NEWS NATION DURING AN INTERVIEW
ON THE NETWORK TUESDAY NIGHT.
I GUESS MATT LAUER WASN'T
AVAILABLE.
WE WENT TO A NEWS NATION VIEWER
FOR COMMENT.
SO GOOD.
TRUE, LIKE ADAM SCHIFF'S
HEARTBEAT.
I DIDN'T KNOW NEWS NATION
EXISTED.
HE MADE THE ANNOUNCEMENT ON DAN
ABRAMS LIVE FROM ON HIS TINY
TINY NETWORK.
BUT HE INSISTED HE ACTUALLY
LIKED THAT NETWORK WAS SO SMALL
BURIED HIM
>> I HAD DECIDED THAT I CAN'T GO
BACK TO WHAT PEOPLE SEE IS THE
BIG GAME.
I DON'T THINK I CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE THERE.
I THINK WE NEED INSURGENT MEDIA.
I THINK WE NEED OUTLETS THAT
AREN'T FRINGE AND JUST TRYING TO
KILL THEIR POCKETS.
>> Greg: IT SOUNDS LIKE WHAT I
SAID ABOUT THE PROM.
I DIDN'T WANT TO GO WITH YOU
ANYWAY, I DON'T EVEN LIKE YOU
AND THAT WASN'T EVEN
SPRAY-PAINTED YOUR CAR.
OF COURSE, THERE ARE NO REPORTS
OF ANY MAJOR NETWORK ACTUALLY
HAVING OFFER HIM A JOB, BUT
THAT'S PROBABLY BECAUSE HE NEVER
PICKED UP THE PHONE, HE WAS TOO
BUSY VOLUNTEERING FOR THE FIRE
DEPARTMENT IN THE HAMPTONS.
YOU KNOW, YOU DON'T HEAR BALL
PLAYERS BRAGGING ABOUT GETTING
SENT TO THE MINORS.
ALTHOUGH AT CNN, GETTING SENT TO
THE MINORS, IT MEANS SOMETHING
ELSE.
>> DARK.
DARK TONIGHT.
>> Greg: YEAH.
BAD.
THAT WAS BAD.
IN THE INTERVIEW, HE INSISTED
THAT PEOPLE COULD TRUST THE WORK
HE WOULD DO ON THE NETWORK.
>> I'M GOING TO TRY VERY HARD TO
BE FAIR.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THAT'S LESS
CONVINCING THAN A DOOR TO DOOR
BUTT IMPLANT SALESMAN.
BUT MAYBE WE COULD SEE MORE
CLASSICS LIKE THIS.
>> THE TURNOUT OF WHITE
SUPREMACIST WAS SIMPLY PATHETIC,
WHICH IS WHY DIDN'T HAVE TO GO
THERE AND COVER.
AS A TRAVESTY MOCKERY.
A TRAVESTY SHAM.
>> WHAT YOU SAY?
WHAT'S GET AFTER IT.
>> IT'S A BIG NIGHT, WHAT DO YOU
SAY?
LET'S GET AFTER IT.
>> Greg: IF CHRIS CAN MAKE
THIS KIND OF CABLE NEWS COME
BACK, THERE'S DEFTLY HOPE FOR
HIS BROTHER TO MAKE A SIMILAR
ONE.
LOOK FOR HIM ON COURT TV AS AN
ANALYST OR A DEFENDANT.
CAT,
KAT, DO YOU BELIEVE HE ACTUALLY
LIKES THAT THE NETWORK A SMALL?
>> NOBODY BELIEVES THAT, WHICH
IS WHY DON'T LIKE -- HE JUST
CAN'T HELP HIMSELF.
SAYS HE MAY THINK I GOT DEMOTED
BECAUSE OF MY MULTIFACETED
SCANDAL THAT INVOLVED BOTH MY
JOURNALISTIC INTEGRITY AND
SEXUAL HARASSMENT WHATEVER,
MISCONDUCT.
BUT I ACTUALLY LIKE IT, AND THE
REASON I LIKE IT IS BECAUSE I
CAN BETTER HELP YOU.
I COULD DO THE WORK MORE TO HELP
YOU.
THE THING IS, WITH THIS GUY,
WHEN HE THOUGHT ABOUT THAT, HE'S
LIKE OH, THIS IS GOOD.
THIS IS GOOD.
THIS IS GOING TO MAKE THIS NOT
EMBARRASSING FOR ME.
AND IT HONESTLY IS.
>> YOU CAN'T READ PEOPLE'S
MINDS, BUT YOU CAN READ HIS.
YOU KNOW EXACTLY -- SHE'S LIKE
OH, HOW DO I LOOK RIGHT NOW, I
LOOK REALLY GOOD.
THIS POINT ABOUT BEING INSURGENT
MEDIA, TYRUS, YOU KNOW HOW HAPPY
I AM ABOUT THIS, RIGHT?
I CALLED YOU AT 4:00 A.M. WHEN I
FOUND OUT.
>> HE'S BACK ON HIS BACK, LIKE
WHO, THE BAD MAN UNDER YOUR BED?
>> Greg: YOU KNOW I COULDN'T
SLEEP.
>> YOU'RE NOT GOING TO SLEEP FOR
PROBABLY MONTHS.
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED.
I THINK IS GOING TO LET YOU
DOWN.
YOU SAW HIM.
GOING TO TRY TO KEEP IT
STRAIGHT.
GIVE THE NEWS TO THE 17 PEOPLE
THAT ARE WATCHING.
IT'S A LITTLE DISCOURAGING,
BECAUSE THE ENTIRE PORTION OF
NEWS NATION WAS WHERE JUST GOING
TO DO NEWS, WE DON'T CARE ABOUT
RATINGS, THIS IS A NEUTRAL PLACE
WHERE WE JUST REPORT THE NEWS.
THEY EVEN PROMISED TO MAKE
BREAKING NEWS BREAKING NEWS
AGAIN.
AND THEN THEY BROKE NEWS WITH
THIS.
THE STUDENT, HE IS LIKE EVERY
GUY WHOSE WIFE LEFT HIM FOR A
YOUNGER GUY AND GOT EVERYTHING
AND HE'S IN HIS STUDIO APARTMENT
AND HIS RELUCTANTLY HAVE TO
VISIT HIM AND HE'S LIKE THIS IS
SUCH A GREAT START FOR ME.
LIKE I AM SO EXCITED.
I GOT MY BUS PASS, YOU KNOW, I'M
THREE BLOCKS AWAY FROM THE YMCA.
THIS IS -- YOU GUYS ARE GOING
TO -- KIDS, STOP CRYING.
NO, YOU CAN'T GO HOME.
I CALL YOUR MOTHER BUT SHE GOT
MY CELL PHONE.
THIS IS LITERALLY -- BUT HE'S
TRYING TO MAKE A GREAT SITUATION
OUT OF -- IT'S OVER, IT'S DONE.
>> Greg: YOU REALIZE THAT
JAMIE IS WATCHING YOU MAKE
>> YES.
HE DIDN'T GET AN APARTMENT.
>> Greg: GUY, I LOVE THE FACT
THAT HE SEES HIMSELF AS A REBEL.
>> COME THIS IS GOING TO BE
INSURGENT MEDIA, WE ARE FRIENDS.
YOU KNOW THOSE GIANT NETWORKS?
THEIR FRIENDS.
>> THE SON AND BROTHER OF A
GOVERNOR IS THE ULTIMATE
UNDERDOG TALE, RIGHT?
THAT'S THE CHRIS CUOMO STORY.
IF YOU'RE THE ONE PERSON IN
AMERICA CLAMORING FOR HIS
COMEBACK.
THE ONLY ONE, IT'S YOU.
>> Greg: I WAS BEHIND US FROM
THE BEGINNING.
>> HIS WHOLE MONOLOGUE BEGGING
CNN TO NOT FIRE HIM.
>> I DID.
I DID.
>> YOU WANT HIM AS A GUEST.
>> Greg: I WANT HIM HERE AT
FOX, ON "THE FIVE"!
>> THIS NETWORK IS FAR TOO BIG
FOR HIS TASTE AS HE TELLS US.
BUT I ACTUALLY DISAGREE, I TAKE
HIM AT HIS WORD THAT HE LIKES
WORKING AT A SMALL NETWORK
BECAUSE HE SEEMS TO ENJOY IT AT
CNN.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THAT WAS REALLY MEAN.
I LIKE IT.
DEAN, FIRST OF ALL, HOW DO WE
FIND THIS STATION?
>> HONESTLY, TYRUS KNEW SO MUCH
ABOUT IT, I NEVER HEARD ABOUT
IT.
THE GO I HEARD ABOUT IT TODAY.
>> I WOULD LIKE WHERE IS HE
GOING?
>> KEEP LOOKING, GOING NEWS
NATION?
>> I HAD NEVER HEARD ABOUT UNTIL
THIS RIGHT HERE.
AND I'M PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
EVER HEAR ABOUT IT AGAIN UNTIL I
WATCH YOUR SHOW WHEN YOU MAKE
FUN OF HIM BUT MIGHT HAVE HAVE
MATERIAL FOR THE NEXT SIX
MONTHS.
>> Greg: THE ONLY WHEN GOING
TO BE ABLE TO FIND MATERIAL IS
IF I FIND THE STATION, AND I'M
NOT GOING TO DO THAT, BUT I HAVE
TO RELY ON SOME BODY ELSE TO
LOOK FOR THE LITTLE BITS AND
PIECES.
>> YOU'VE GOT THREE PRODUCERS
ASSIGNED TO THAT RIGHT NOW
ALREADY.
>> IS GOING TO HIRE SOMEONE TO
WATCH NEWS NATION ALL DAY.
>> Greg: WILL PROBABLY BE
THERE CEO.
ANYWAY, I WANT YOU THINK -- I
THINK IT'S DAN ABRAMS, RIGHT?
THAT'S THE GUY WHO'S IN CHARGE
OF THIS THING, SO THANK YOU,
DAN.
WE OWE